We have so far discussed the
first step involved in the
construction of a probabilistic
model.
Namely, the construction of
a sample space, which is a
description of the possible
outcomes of a probabilistic
experiment.
We now come to the second and
much more interesting part.
We need to specify which
outcomes are more likely to
occur and which ones are less
likely to occur and so on.
And we will do that by assigning
probabilities to the
different outcomes.
However, as we try to do this
assignment, we run into some
kind of difficulty, which
is the following.
Remember the previous experiment
involving a
continuous sample space, which
was the unit square and in
which we throw a dart at random
and record the point
that occurred.
In this experiment, what do you
think is the probability
of a particular point?
Let's say what is the
probability that my dart hits
exactly the center
of this square.
Well, this probability would
be essentially 0.
Hitting the center exactly
with infinite
precision should be 0.
And so it's natural that in such
a continuous model any
individual point should
have a 0 probability.
For this reason instead of
assigning probabilities to
individual points, we will
instead assign probabilities
to whole sets, that is, to
subsets of the sample space.
So here we have our sample
space, which is some
abstract set omega.
Here is a subset of
the sample space.
Call it capital A. We're going
to assign a probability to
that subset A, which we're
going to denote with this
notation, which we read as the
probability of set A. So
probabilities will be
assigned to subsets.
And these will not cause us
difficulties in the continuous
case because even though
individual points would have 0
probability, if you ask me what
are the odds that my dart
falls in the upper half, let's
say, of this diagram, then
that should be a reasonable
positive number.
So even though individual
outcomes may have 0
probabilities, sets of outcomes
in general would be
expected to have positive
probabilities.
So coming back, we're going to
assign probabilities to the
various subsets of
the sample space.
And here comes a piece of
terminology, that a subset of
the sample space is
called an event.
Why is it called an event?
Because once we carry out the
experiment and we observe the
outcome of the experiment,
either this outcome is inside
the set A and in that case we
say that event A has occurred,
or the outcome falls outside the
set A in which case we say
that event A did not occur.
Now we want to move on and
describe certain rules.
The rules of the game in
probabilistic models, which
are basically the
rules that these
probabilities should satisfy.
They shouldn't be completely
arbitrary.
First, by convention,
probabilities are always given
in the range between 0 and 1.
Intuitively, 0 probability means
that we believe that
something practically
cannot happen.
And probability of 1 means that
we're practically certain
that an event of interest
is going to happen.
So we want to specify rules of
these kind for probabilities.
These rules that any
probabilistic model should
satisfy are called the axioms
of probability theory.
And our first axiom is a
nonnegativity axiom.
Namely, probabilities
will always be
non-negative numbers.
It's a reasonable rule.
The second rule is that if the
subset that we're looking at
is actually not a subset but
is the entire sample space
omega, the probability of it
should always be equal to 1.
What does that mean?
We know that the outcome is
going to be an element of the
sample space.
This is the definition
of the sample space.
So we have absolute certainty
that our outcome is going to
be in omega.
Or in different language we have
absolute certainty that
event omega is going to occur.
And we capture this certainty by
saying that the probability
of event omega is equal to 1.
These two axioms are pretty
simple and very intuitive.
The more interesting axiom
is the next one that says
something a little
more complicated.
Before we discuss that
particular axiom, a quick
reminder about set theoretic
notation.
If we have two sets, let's say
a set A, and another set,
another set B, we use this
particular notation, which we
read as "A intersection B" to
refer to the collection of
elements that belong to both A
and B. So in this picture, the
intersection of A and B
is this shaded set.
We use this notation, which we
read as "A union B", to refer
to the set of elements
that belong to A
or to B or to both.
So in terms of this picture,
the union of the two sets
would be this blue set.
After this reminder about set
theoretic notation, now let us
look at the form of
the third axiom.
What does it say?
If we have two sets, two events,
two subsets of the
sample space, which
are disjoint.
So here's our sample space.
And here are the two sets
that are disjoint.
In mathematical terms, two sets
being disjoint means that
their intersection
has no elements.
So their intersection
is the empty set.
And we use this symbol here
to denote the empty set.
So if the intersection of two
sets is empty, then the
probability that the outcome
of the experiments falls in
the union of A and B, that is,
the probability that the
outcome is here or there, is
equal to the sum of the
probabilities of
these two sets.
This is called the
additivity axiom.
So it says that we can add
probabilities of different
sets when those two
sets are disjoint.
In some sense we can think of
probability as being one pound
of some substance which is
spread over our sample space
and the probability of A is how
much of that substance is
sitting on top of a set A. So
what this axiom is saying is
that the total amount of that
substance sitting on top of A
and B is how much is sitting on
top of A plus how much is
sitting on top of B. And that is
the case whenever the sets
A and B are disjoint
from each other.
The additivity axiom needs
to be refined a bit.
We will talk about that
a little later.
Other than this refinement,
these three axioms are the
only requirements in
order to have a
legitimate probability model.
At this point you may ask,
shouldn't there be more
requirements?
Shouldn't we, for example, say
that probabilities cannot be
greater than 1?
Yes and no.
We do not want probabilities to
be larger than 1, but we do
not need to say it.
As we will see in the next
segment, such a requirement
follows from what we
have already said.
And the same is true for
several other natural
properties of probabilities.